Rebecca is with us in Spokane Washington
hi Rebecca how are you better than I
deserve what's up kind of did things
backwards so he's in the military and I
work 120 325 we have thirty thousand
dollars in savings but we do have car
debt
so my husband sees car payments that's
just a monthly expense she sees it as
just a monthly bill I dunno I see them
as you pay him off they keep him forever
so what I'm trying to decide if we're at
a point where we're thinking about
starting a family and I don't know if I
want to stay at home why not so I'm
gonna pass my Nissan which we only owe
eight thousand on in the next six months
I already have a plan that's going to
get done but the hard guy we owe $26 so
what I'm thinking about doing is paying
taking 10,000 on a savings putting it
towards the Honda that'll save us a
thousand bucks on interest and then once
my Nissan is paid off I'll take the two
things what is your household income we
make about 70,000 a year combined but
that will be cut in half if I stop
working we have a baby
yeah you can't afford this Honda you
don't think two years it's more than
half your annual income when you had
your two cars together you have too much
as an after-tax though you too much
invest in these things you have too much
invested in things that are going down
in value
thank you think we should be what fella
mmm-hmm see this is not gonna work
though because your husband is bent he's
convinced that he's always gonna have a
car payment and so guess what guess what
he's always gonna have a car payment and
as long as as long as you think that way
I really can't help you because you are
100% going to remain middle-class you
are never going to build serious wealth
as long as you buy large assets that go
down in value on payments this is too
stupid things combined about the only
thing you could do that would be dumber
would be to a
put it on a credit card large items that
go down in value and pay payments on
them and you call that a way of life
that that's a hundred percent guaranteed
mathematical fact you are not gonna win
with money while you're doing that and
so you're gonna have to talk this
through with him because he's just
straight-up wrong and you guys probably
need to get rid of this Honda large
items that go down in value with
payments on them does not equal wealth
building it equals middle-class at best
you're gonna struggle your whole lives
this is the Dave Ramsey show